how's um res - welcome back oh my god
bros this is the last episode of sims
because Jenny's gonna die I think I hope
I don't have to play long for him
tonight
so Nathan if you missed the last episode
you're gonna be confused as [ __ ] but
Felix myself had a baby and Chan had a
baby and so now we have two black little
babies that we have to somehow take care
of their call as one and ask - no no no
no Chan Chan no oh no plead for Chan
plead for Chan Chan no everyone's crying
plead China's dead
no it's still alive actually he's just
peed himself this is really trying to
play it off by dying we're like maybe if
I pretend that I'm dying no one will
notice
oh come on he's dead all right well
let's talk to him
I oh we're really hitting it up you just
killed my boyfriend but I really like
Jeff huh tell a funny story I don't know
you could do this this is [ __ ] up
while all the babies are just crying
feelings like yeah you know what the
floors are really wet I should probably
mop them there's something really [ __ ]
up about having the babies crying in the
background - this game just got really
weird
kiss hands I can do that are you [ __ ]
kidding me what that why we're really
hitting it off here we're death this is
let's gossip a little bit about Chan he
accepted my rose what death is flirty
no [ __ ] way let's compliment his
outfit this is the weirdest thing that
ever happened to me in this game oh my
god it's going really well
no don't go we were hitting it off so
well
I'm such a great father I still haven't
acknowledged the fact that Chan died a
lot of strange things happening in
Asheville a lot of strange things
happening
I want death to come back we were going
so well I can age him up already
oh well aren't you a little [ __ ] as
you'd look nothing like me is this my
daughter
Jesus why is my daughter crying she's
sad over Oh of her dad of course
I haven't really cash yet too busy
sleeping it says I need to summon back
Satan I I don't want to kill ass but if
she dies it's not my fault all right
hey hey oh great idea we don't have to
kill our daughter we can kill someone
else
let's see might them in this is perfect
what the [ __ ] is with her she murdered
someone why is her blood on her boots
alright she's clearly a murderer we
should probably kill her this game
really gets more funny after time this
is ridiculous so I caught this murderer
and we're gonna try and kill her and
wonder if there's a better way to kill
her though I should really get going now
thanks for hanging out with me see you
later okay whatever you say all right we
can age this baby up let's do it let's
see how he looks like okay this one he's
a boy and he's blond he's such a Swedish
person oh my god well she ever died God
let's go in there together yes
and then let's stay there forever
you guys having fun in there what how
did he escape how how did he do it
how is that possible how did he escape
from the acelin get it get it that was
the best day I ever made you have to get
it I love how the babies are crying more
about Chan than I ever did look how
happy I am
it's so [ __ ] up maybe I should get it
to know my children a little bit I
actually have never talked to them she's
talking on the phone with someone about
pots and trains cuz that's what you do
when you're about to die yes yes she's
dying
finally oh I've waited for you my
darling how do I talk to him I need to
talk to him I wonder if he remembers me
he does but it's been so long
he loved the rose oh my god this is so
weird
okay now we can maybe kiss his hands Wow
I got an achievement for that that's
awesome and trying so hard
I mean cheating to do it alright we're
going in the bedroom this is all going
fun so far so good
Wow make a move this will be very
interesting oh my god what am i doing he
killed your wife what it you Oh God you
[ __ ] he really doesn't get tired of
compliments either it's kind of nice I'm
gonna [ __ ] him if it's the last thing
I'll ever do god damnit of retirement
leaves its [ __ ] impossible okay
we're gonna have to befriend someone and
then kill him to meet him again yes yes
[ __ ] is dying
yes she's dying from laughter yeah I
read it for this there we go
that's our chance to swoop in uh hey
babe I missed you where have you been
what took you so long
yes well I say I've been trying for
hours to get laid
with his bee no one's gonna interrupt
our sexy time god damn it wait deaf
offers me rose how can I not be happy
from that who what the [ __ ] happened to
my face what the [ __ ] is that
what what happened to my face my face is
melting from being with that what what
is this who did that what happened to my
daughter why is this a penance
I just came back to check what the
actual [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] am i doing
she's sleep oh oh she's saying yes my
love is back my love my love my life my
love my love okay this is our moment my
senpai is here he has a [ __ ] iPad
Steve Steve ace are you in there the
[ __ ]
it's Travis birthday this is the saddest
syphilis look how happy I am I don't
even give a [ __ ] yeah selfie that will
not be a weird selfie at all I ship them
so much why can they not be together sit
together come on come on Debs
sit with me yes no don't go yes yea-ah I
tried for hours breasts are getting
tired of this I'm gonna try if I die if
maybe then we can be together oh no this
is the end mm what'd you say mmm that
you only meant oh no my my senpai is
gonna take my life ya ass is crying nice
v-neck man why is she laughing what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
what the youth bipolar [ __ ] there it
comes
what no way I live I live I'm alive
somebody couldn't simply I couldn't do
it we may not be able to make demon
babies but deaf will not hold our Romans
apart I think well that took a weird
turn I almost died but I go straight of
flirting and he's gone well Bruce I
think that that about does it
we can't make demon babies but we can
have demon love I tried so hard to lose
it all but in the end we live in
Asheville so it's okay hope you bros
enjoyed this episode if you did go ahead
and hit that like button really
appreciate both and I will see you in
the next one invisible brofist stay
awesome
[Music]